[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son nuestros invitados y
con ellos conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre los temas que vamos a
desarrollar en el programa de hoy hemos
invitado a bastián Díaz ls periodista de
temas internacionales del diario La
tercera de chile bastian Gracias por
estar con nosotros y qué tal termina
usted su semana Buenos días Qué tal ha
sido una semana bastante dura sobre todo
luego de lo hecho ocurrido en Brasil en
Brasilia donde estuvo este asalto de la
de los funcionaristas y en realidad ha
sido bastante arduo te querés que te
diga
semana ardua con muchísimo trabajo creo
que para todas las reacciones
periodísticas en América Latina también
les recuerdo a ustedes que nos pueden
acompañar con sus opiniones y
comentarios y también sus preguntas por
supuesto a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran como arroba France
24_es@santalogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral una semana en
el mundo f24 vamos a comenzar entonces
en Suramérica Perú sigue acaparando la
atención internacional por supuesto la
inestabilidad política las
manifestaciones y los desmanes han
dejado más de 40 personas muertas en los
últimos días en ese país precisamente
Perú está intentando regresar a la
normalidad en medio de un clima de
rechazo al gobierno de Dina boluarte y
también entre el rechazo y los reclamos
por el caso del destituido expresidente
Pedro Castillo en un intento por
apaciguar los ánimos y también por
tratar de calmar un poco la situación el
congreso peruano aprobó la creación de
una comisión que deberá Investigar la
muerte de los ciudadanos que
participaron en las manifestaciones
principalmente en el sur del país Perú y
sus constantes crisis políticas pues es
nuestro tema de inicio comenzó dándole
entonces la palabra abaster mientras
retomamos conexión con nuestra siguiente
invitada que la voy a presentar más
adelante bastián entonces Perú
acaparando los titulares internacionales
no solamente en la región y un constante
espiral de crisis de violencia de
ingobernabilidad cómo lo ve
una situación bastante complicada ya
desde el momento en que Pedro Castillo
hace este intento de golpe de estado que
fue cuando cerró el congreso
entra esta espiral de del gobierno no
podría decir tiene Volverte entra al
poder sin necesariamente tener el apoyo
de la población y hay en este momento
una una serie de protestas que empezaron
desde la misma semana en que ya tomó el
poder entonces
lo que se ve por lo menos el Horizonte
hay gente que espera su renuncia hay
gente que
es que esperan las nuevas elecciones que
hasta un momento se dicen empiezan en
2024 Pero hay gente que las quisiera más
pronto Esta es su problema actualmente
en Perú Sí y ahora con la nueva con la
nueva persecución con la nueva
investigación que va a ser la fiscalía
respecto a acusando de genocidio
investigando por ejemplo así dio a la
presidenta se ve mucho más complicado el
tema basteni Cómo se percibe este tema
esta crisis política y de gobernabilidad
en Chile un país vecino que tiene una
relación una relación que históricamente
ha sido de tira y afloje entre Santiago
y Lima como ven ustedes vecinos de Perú
lo que sucede allí
yo creo que normalmente con más
incertidumbre con preocupación no es
algo nunca Es bueno tener un vecino en
ese nivel de inestabilidad me imagino
uno preferiría que hay que si supiera lo
que está ocurriendo ahí que hubiera Un
gobierno fijo o un gobierno estable
saber con qué contamos al otro lado en
Lima me imagino en este momento por
ejemplo cuando estaba Pedro castillo y
recién había entrado borich se podía
haber haber una relación más fluida pero
ahora hacer relaciones tener relaciones
con Dina boluarte sabiendo que
probablemente no es algo que va a estar
no es alguien que va a estar ahí todo el
tiempo al final siendo un país vecino es
un una fuente de inestabilidad muy
grande claro te doy la bienvenida a
nuestra siguiente invitada Verónica
Mondragón ella es editora de la sección
global de excelsior la saludamos a ella
en México Verónica Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos Y qué
tal termina usted su semana
Hola Es un gusto estar con ustedes
pues con mucho mucha información una
situación muy interesante muy convulsa
en América Latina en varios de nuestros
países
pisando el tema de Perú de esta crisis y
estas manifestaciones que han tenido
lugar a lo largo de la semana ya lo
estamos conversando con con bastián
desde México cómo se ve Entonces esta
crisis en Sudamérica
bueno por supuesto el tema de Perú es
muy importante para México por supuesto
No solo porque tenemos una relación pues
como países vecinos por supuesto en
México se ha percibido con mucha
cercanía por supuesto por las relaciones
que tiene el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador con Pedro Castillo incluso
desde antes que se llevara a cabo la el
intento de autogolpe de nuestro país
pues se acercó a Perú ambos países e
incluso desde la campaña entonces pues
para México ha sido un tema muy
importante este México ha tenido
contacto con funcionarios de varios
poderes en en Perú de varias instancias
para brindar asesoría Entonces en cuanto
se dio la el intento de golpe de estado
fue muy importante para México incluso
sabemos que la hora expresidente Pedro
Castillo buscaba refugio en nuestra
embajada Entonces por supuesto para
México desde el siete de diciembre
cuando empezó
antes ha sido un tema de Gran relevancia
un tema de Gran relevancia importancia
allá en México Verónica continuó con
usted para preguntarle hemos visto
varios presidentes pasar por el poder en
Perú Usted cree que boluarte Dina
boluarte terminará este periodo
presidencial interino es a la gran
pregunta que se hace en los analistas si
ella logrará darle un poco de
estabilidad al país y logrará terminar
porque también es cierto que ya
comienzan a cerrarse algunos espacios
políticos y empiezan ya a hablar de una
vacancia
efectivamente como comparto también la
gran pregunta si si la actual presidenta
interina llegará al final se excederán
en las presiones de elecciones
anticipadas es difícil pues ver un
pronóstico sobre todo por justo el tema
de las manifestaciones que está
creciendo cada vez más el rechazo a la
presidenta en determinadas zonas sobre
todo con el decreto de toque de queda es
está generando descontento Y por
supuesto pues esto genera más presión
hacia ella y por supuesto aumenta la
posibilidad de que se tenga que llegar a
las elecciones anticipadas bastián y su
opinión usted tiene que terminar el
mandato o no
en realidad una situación bastante
complicada uno no puede decir de acá
marzo de acá junio
yo lo que lo veo es que sumado a la a la
investigación de fiscalía sumado a la
poca popularidad que tuvo desde el
principio y que no y que muy poco
probable que de acá los próximos meses
vaya a ganar cierta popularidad o apoyo
del Congreso
lo es lo que uno no quisiera que hubiera
otro presidente más hubiera otro pero ya
han habido muchos cambios y es y no le
veo mucho futuro yo personalmente no es
lo que quisiera pero es una situación
tan complicada en Perú que en realidad
es viendo lo que se pide mucho la
adelanto de las elecciones viendo que no
es un gobierno popular y que en este
momento hay muchos hay muchos muertos
muchos muertos en las protestas peruanas
es una situación grave y no veo que ha
de volverte tenga muchas piezas que
mover además de su misma renuncia
Verónica bastian no sé si ustedes
comparten esta duda que voy a exponer y
voy a poner aquí sobre la mesa y es esta
comisión que aprobó el congreso peruano
que tiene 90 días para investigar
justamente lo que menciona bastian que
son las muertes de estos ciudadanos en
diferentes manifestaciones
principalmente en el sur van a
esclarecer si esto fue producto de
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas
militares con la policía o el ejército
peruano y ellos son los causantes de
estas muertes o si fueron por otro tipo
de causas esto pone en vilo y es tal vez
mi preocupación aquí que la
investigación ponga en vilo al gobierno
de boluarte que evidencia que esto tuvo
compromiso por parte del Estado que el
estado se vea comprometido en las
muertes de estas personas y sea una
causa Para que lleven a la destitución
de la mandataria cómo lo ven ustedes
comienzo con Verónica
claro Bueno yo pienso que agrega un
elemento más al descontento que se
siente actualmente hacia boluarte no
estoy segura que en sí misma la
investigación se pueda convertir o nos
pueda llevar a su renuncia
Definitivamente creo que abona
Y por supuesto Pues creo que será
necesario
mantener la exigencia de que la
investigación se llegue a fondo Porque
si se queda algún vacío o se queda
incompleta Me parece que no por sí sola
no llegará a la destitución de boluarte
y bastián su opinión
mi opinión al respecto si esta
investigación puede o no hacer la
renuncia de boluarte
no solo eso no es solo eso lo que está
tirando hacia atrás está
haciendo un hoyo en el en el gobierno de
boluarte ya con estas protestas ya con
la popularidad baja que tenía ya Con el
poco apoyo que tiene en otras
instituciones
no será este el el la la el gatillo de
sino que muchos motivos que no aseguran
la gobernabilidad
en el Perú
para ir cerrando el tema para ir
avanzando con la agenda continuó con
bastián para para cerrar este tema
Cómo salir de esta espiral vamos a
seguir titulando esta crisis política en
Perú Este es otro capítulo más ustedes
creen que esto todavía da para un tiempo
más prolongado en el cubrimiento de la
situación que se está dando en Perú
porque la crisis pues simplemente
todavía no está próximo o no se ve esa
luz al final del túnel en el corto plazo
es que esa luz al final del túnel lo más
cercano que veo serían unas próximas
elecciones una una reestructuración no
sé si el congreso del o de la
presidencia pero
está muy difícil que se salga de una de
esta crisis si no si no hay elecciones
si no hay si no hay algo que contenta
todo el pueblo peruano grandes
Así que eso yo creo que si hubiera una
luz al final del túnel tendría que venir
con elecciones y Verónica hay luz al
final del túnel lo vamos a seguir
titulando estas constantes crisis y
episodios de crisis de Perú
yo desearía por supuesto por el bien de
Perú y por el bien del resto de América
Latina que este pues este capítulo que
se agravó mucho en Perú nos pueda llevar
un puerto que se pudiera ya salir de
esto Lamentablemente la situación creció
mucho y pues mi mayor deseo es que
definitivamente
este pues este esta situación significa
ya la salida y la salida de este túnel
pues quedan muchas preguntas y todavía
este tema está en desarrollo todo puede
suceder en las próximas horas o en los
próximos días en Perú cualquier cosa
puede suceder allí y puede dar un
desenlace o llevarnos a otro episodio
así por lo menos nos lo ha demostrado
los hechos de las últimas semanas o de
los últimos meses allí en Perú vamos por
supuesto a seguir atentos a lo que
suceda allí pero otro país que también
vivió un remesón político en los últimos
días fue Brasil no ha sido un buen Punto
de partida para el gobierno del nuevo
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el
gigante suramericano intenta ya regresar
a la calma después de esos disturbios
que dejaron seriamente dañadas las sedes
de los tres poderes públicos en la
ciudad de Brasilia en la capital de ese
país suramericano el presidente Lula da
Silva dijo que hubo complicidad por
parte de la policía que estaba
custodiando el lugar que fue atacado
como ya lo sabemos por Seguidores del
expresidente Jair bolsonaro que a través
de las redes sociales se desligó por
completo del tema Un inicio muy
complicado para el presidente Lula y en
Brasil Un inicio de un gobierno que ya
marca una Pauta de una agenda
creo que muy distinta la que estaba
planteando el presidente Verónica no sé
si usted lo vea Así es el análisis que
yo hago era un enfoque muy social y muy
económico pero ahora parece que el
enfoque va a tener que ser en sanar el
país en unificar el país y reducir esa
polarización que análisis hace usted
Por supuesto Lula de Silva empieza su
tercer mandato con un gran desafío
él si bien de inicio hablaba de
reconstrucción de unificación ahora se
incorpora otro factor que va a ser la
seguridad
el manejo de no solo de Brasilia sino a
nivel nacional
por supuesto se esperaba Un inicio de un
mandato completamente diferente sin
embargo no fue así Lula llevaba siete
días de haber tomado protesta por
supuesto es una consecuencia de lo que
había estado viviendo el país recordamos
que cuando Yahir bolsonaro llegó al
poder Hace cuatro años y se inició una
campaña en redes sociales que se llamaba
él no el rechazo eso nos dejaba ver que
iba a ser una unas presidencia difícil
para él y bueno incluso cuando ya se fue
vimos este ataque la sede de los tres
poderes y la perspectiva de este tema
bastian
sigo lo dicho con Verónica respecto a
que esto agrega no solo el tema social
que era muy importante para el gobierno
de urula sino el tema de la seguridad y
qué hacer ahora con los ya casi mil
doscientos más de mil pesos que tiene
este ataque por ejemplo la última
manifestaciones en contra ya de este
ataque se ha hablado mucho del sin
amnistía de esta idea de que no se vaya
a mixtear o hacer un perdonazo a quienes
resultaron presos en este asalto a los
tres poderes y en realidad hay que ver
cómo
radicalizar
a la extrema derecha brasileña porque si
no vamos a tener constantes amenazas o
esta constante amenaza que ya quedó de
que es posible que pueda ocurrir que en
algún día se organicen miles de personas
y ataquen en los tres poderes del estado
que fue lo que ocurrió este domingo
pasado
bastián continuó con usted y le preguntó
esto puede y es una gran pregunta que se
hacen los los analistas es el efecto que
esto pueda tener en la región en América
Latina sobre todo en esos países donde
también hay polarización y que también
se enfrentan a un escenario electoral en
los próximos meses estoy hablando Por
ejemplo de Guatemala y por ejemplo
Argentina un país que está muy
polarizado también a nivel político y
hay temor que escenarios similares se
puedan producir usted ve indicios de un
efecto bola de nieve y que se presenten
hechos parecidos
de momentos si hablásemos de Argentina
no me imagino que haya no sé un no veo
en el escenario de Argentina por ejemplo
un ataque a la casa rosada un ataque de
de mayor violencia porque o por lo menos
algo que encuentro a Brasil es que
Brasil tuvo estos cuatro años donde se
hubo organizaciones donde la extrema
derecha se organizó donde alrededor de
bolsonaro un montón de organizaciones
hubieron estascletadas En voto que
hacían esta marchas en moto se hicieron
grupos en WhatsApp
los militares el negocio
El agricultor hay Iglesias hubo cierta
plataforma política que permitió al
final conseguir estos grupos y
radicalizar gente y hacer que la gente
estuviese dispuesta a ir en bus y atacar
Brasilia en este momento no creo que
haya ese tipo de plataformas aún en
Argentina como si la subo en Estados
Unidos para
un par de años entonces hay que ver eso
es interesante
ver cómo esta radicalización necesita de
gente que está dispuesta a poner su
cuerpo ahí y en este momento Si llegase
a ganar la oposición a Alberto Fernández
hoy llegaste a ganar en el 20 de todos
no veo en el otro lado eso
entiendo y Verónica aquí hay un punto
importante y es el estado de las
democracias en América Latina hemos
visto este descontento que hay digamos
general en la mayoría de los países la
mayoría de los estados han presenciado
manifestaciones ciudadanas
desde hace ya un par de años pero este
este hecho que ocurrió en Brasilia no se
puede tomar como un hecho aislado o
simplemente como un malestar por parte
de los ciudadanos por haber perdido la
lección presidencial en ese intento del
expresidente bolsonaro de ser reelegido
aquí hay algo más usted hace una lectura
entre líneas de esta toma de las de
estas tres sedes de los poderes públicos
allí en Brasilia hay algo más que no
estamos viendo
entre líneas y lo estamos dejando un
poco superficial
Bueno a mí coincido con lo que con lo
que comentábamos hace un momento
definitivamente existió la plataforma
para que se llegara al ataque a los tres
poderes creo que una gran lección para
nuestra región es revisar que ocurrió
antes de ese asalto no la respuesta sino
lo que ocurrió antes si se difundió
información por redes sociales por
canales extraoficiales qué tanto fue
fácil para la población para la para la
oposición con la que tiene hoy
Brasil que tanto fue fácil llegar ahí
cuál fue por supuesto la prevención por
parte de las policías de Brasilia si
realmente se prepararon para eso porque
se se imaginaba que podíamos llegar a
esto y finalmente ocurrió entonces creo
que la gran elección es ver qué pasó
antes Y a partir de ahí pues realmente
tomar acciones que no nos puedan
llegar a lo que vimos en el asalto a
Brasil Verónica un punto importante acá
es analizar el papel de los militares la
policía son básicamente los que logran
defender o no a ese mandatario que está
caminando por una línea muy delgada
entre la destitución o la salida del
poder vemos el caso del expresidente
peruano el expresidente Castillo que
estuvo en el poder hasta que
prácticamente los militares le dijeron
no lo vamos a respaldar su gobierno cae
y termina acá Lula en este momento
cuenta con el apoyo de los militares
pero recordemos que el presidente o
expresidente bolsonaro era militar Y
tenía una gran simpatía dentro de los
círculos militares en Brasil y ahora
Lula salió a señalar directamente a los
militares y a la policía de estar
Implicados En y de haber facilitado un
poco que los que los manifestantes
llegaran a estas sedes de estas
instituciones públicas está un poco el
presidente Lula poniéndose una soga al
cuello al señalar a los militares no era
mejor que de pronto lo dijera la
justicia después de las investigaciones
bueno Por supuesto que el papel de los
milita América Latina se ha convertido
en algo fundamental como comentabas el
caso Perú fue un gran ejemplo
Me parece que el presidente Lula hace
señalamientos
específicos intencionalmente no quiere
ser vago en sus señalaciones quiero
ponerle nombre quiero ponerle apellido a
lo que pasó y a las omisiones Me parece
que también eso es lo que lleva a las
instituciones y a la separación de
del gobernador de Brasilia Entonces es
yo creo que hay una intención muy clara
y es justamente la de ponerle rostro a
quien
pudiera haber caído en presuntas o
misiones que llevaron a lo que vimos ese
día sí bastian algo que decir sobre
sobre esta pregunta del papel de los
militares y le prolongó un poco más la
pregunta para empezar a cerrar este tema
y es el papel de bolsonaro qué más va a
ser el expresidente bolsonaro después de
lo que ha sucedido y estar en Estados
Unidos lejos de la Esfera de los medios
brasileños y de la opinión pública
por un lado la función de los militares
importantes porque
hoy lo comentaba precisamente por un
investigador el brasileño que decía que
claro uno podía ver en este ataque que
hubo a Brasil una comparación con el
ataque al Capitolio en el
exactamente 2 años pero la diferencia
entre Estados Unidos y Brasil en este
caso es que claro los militares tienen
un un rol mucho más importante
políticamente son mucho menos neutros en
Brasil que lo que son en Estados Unidos
ahí al menos yo valoro la postura de
Lula de decir Oye tengamos los militares
no sé si Pónganse las pilas pero hagan
lo que hay que hacer
no opinen políticamente o no actúen
políticamente sino que hagan lo que las
constituciones dice y en ese sentido
encuentro importante indicarlo y
apuntarlo por otra parte si hablamos del
rol de bolsonaro y este ataque los
poderes es interesante ver que durante
todo el gobierno bolsonaro el mismo se
comprometió con un discurso que era en
contra de la Corte Suprema que
que atacaba las instituciones y en ese
sentido por senado sigue siendo
responsable incluso de Haber puesto en
duda en algún momento
el sistema electoral brasileño que es el
del voto electrónico sí que muchas veces
se habla de este tema de de Volver al
papel a ver que por lo menos los grupos
de extrema derecha derecha de Brasil se
habla de Volver al papel de desconfiar
de meter esa cizaña en contra el sistema
electoral Entonces ahora aquí le queda
bolsonaro tengo entendido que no puede
quedarse en Estados Unidos Más mucho más
tiempo
y que en Brasil tu panorama no es el
mejor porque hay ya investigaciones
abiertas por distintos posibles crímenes
Entonces por lo menos a mí lo que me han
dicho es que podría irse a Italia O
podría irse Hungría donde están más
presidentes afines pero seriamente su
lugar político sí Y esto quiero cerrar
con esto tu lugar político quizás no
vaya a ser él el líder de su movimiento
del personalismo y lo que dice la
mayoría de los cientistas políticos
y eso es como el problema que podría
quedar y de que puede llegar otro líder
y tomar esta este testamento que dejó
Bolsón Claro que hablamos del 58
millones de personas que lo votaron
Cuál va a ser Vaciar el el desenlace de
estas investigaciones Y qué papel
entonces pasará a jugar en la historia
de Brasil en la historia política el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro vamos a
hablar ahora de la foto de la semana los
llamados Los tres amigos el presidente
de México Andrés Manuel López Obrador su
homólogo Estados Unidos Joe biden y el
Primer Ministro de Canadá Justin se
dieron cita en la llamada cumbre de
Norteamérica en este encuentro los
mandatarios destacaron la necesidad de
seguir apostando por hacer sinergias en
términos comerciales y políticos para
hacer frente a retos medioambientales
comerciales por supuesto migratorios y
económicos pero si uno se pone a mirar
esta foto también hay que pensar y nos
deja también una reflexión sobre la
integración latinoamericana y vemos a
México mucho más interesado en apostarle
a la integración con Norteamérica con
Canadá y Estados Unidos y que hay
entonces de la integración con el resto
del continente con sus países padres que
son hispanos son latinos y también
tienen importancia económica y de peso
en el Continente preguntémosle a
Verónica periodista mexicana sobre este
encuentro la foto de Los tres
mosqueteros como los he llamado yo entre
los tres mandatarios los tres líderes y
esta puesta de México por el norte
efectivamente la Cumbre de los tres los
tres o de tres amigos como le han
llamado bueno vemos una foto una foto
pues que intenta transmitir confianza
amistad pero también vemos en México un
gran cambio en el discurso respecto a la
cercanía con América Latina
fueron unos años complicados por
supuesto en el tema migratorio por
supuesto en el tema del tráfico de droga
principalmente el fentanilo un gran
problema actualmente en Estados Unidos y
ahora bueno vemos Esta esta gran
cercanía como comentabas no solo en el
tema de seguridad también en el tema de
las importaciones buscando algo que no
habíamos visto aquí en México o al menos
no a tal nivel una un Pues un bloque
de respecto a las importaciones
Comparado con china con el fin de Pues
el gigante asiático es un una renovación
o una diferencia en
[Música]
la
internacional Mexicana con lo que
habíamos visto en el actual sexenio
sobre todo con la proyección hacia
América del Norte empezamos con la
cercanía con América Latina y ahora
vemos una distancia de la región y
también una distancia hacia otras
potencias principalmente la China y no
solamente México o sea distanciado un
poco América Latina el gobierno biden
también ha guardado cierta distancia con
América Latina y la apuesta más a otras
regiones del mundo bastian su opinión
e interesante sobre todo esta cumbre en
el contexto de baile en el contexto de
Estados Unidos que viene de vivir sus
elecciones de medio término y como tal
se han recibido un poco Como no una
victoria demócrata Pero al menos un
empate demócrata que al final lo que lo
han logrado han perdido la cámara de
representantes y con eso biden llega a
México y llega con nuevos anuncios sobre
migración llega con esta esta idea de
ofrecer 30 mil plazas para que en
migrantes Centroamericanos llegue a
Estados Unidos pero con esta buena
noticia viene la mala de Por así decirlo
el el tapón de no permitir que cierta
gente que pueda entrar con más con mayor
dureza por un plan de mayor dureza a la
hora de la migración que es el tema
caliente que siempre ha tenido Estados
Unidos con México en ese sentido vaiden
no la tiene fácil porque tiene por un
lado los republicanos que le piden ser
maduro con migración y por el otro a los
demócratas más más progresistas que
encuentran en eso una traición a las
promesas hechas durante la primera
campaña presidencial digo durante la
campaña claro No sé si ustedes coinciden
también en una perspectiva Y es que se
dejó de lado hablar de los países que
originan la migración
Haití Venezuela Colombia El Triángulo
del Norte en Centroamérica
no hablaron de de posibles proyectos
para ayudar a esos países para evitar la
migración ustedes piensan que eso de
pronto quedó ahí como en el aire
rápidamente por favor bastian para hacer
la ronda la inversa
Sí porque es verdad eso que en este
momento se habló más de crisis ambiental
que se habló más de otros puntos y es un
cambio por lo menos un cambio bien
fuerte porque los años anteriores se
había hablado harto de paquetes de ayuda
para El Salvador para Guatemala para
Nicaragua y es precisamente de estos
países y ahora se suma Haití De dónde
viene el mayor flujo migratorio que está
subiendo a Estados Unidos a Estados
Unidos el otro el otro punto importante
es tiene que ver con las empresas
canadienses y con la con el lugar que
tienen la economía mexicana y la y esta
sinergia que están tratando de hacer de
modo económico como bloque en el en el
norte de América sí Verónica su opinión
sobre este tema migratorio Porque además
tengo que aclarar este tema de la
migración ya había sido tratado en la
Cumbre de las Américas a la que No
asistió el presidente mexicano pero allí
había grandes conclusiones a nivel
continental y ahora pues este grupo que
es el foco de A dónde va la mayoría de
migrantes el tema no no profundizaron en
él
bueno por supuesto
[Música]
no hay no hay un gran avance no hay un
gran anuncio
últimamente se ha focalizado a ciertos
países
únicamente
por supuesto fue el tema de la Cumbre
pero también ambos países han estado
negociando
este tema En diversas ocasiones Incluso
se habló también de que la migración
podía llevar a a que México recibiera
donativos de vacunas por parte de
Estados Unidos
a cambio de mayor control migratorio
principalmente en la en la frontera sur
de México Entonces aunque en esta Cumbre
se ha
abordado no lo suficiente
hemos tenido otros momentos de
encuentros en los que la migración ha
sido un tema que está ahí persistente
principalmente porque bueno para el
electorado del bailen es una gran
exigencia Claro pues lo que queda sobre
la mesa es esa integración entre estos
tres países una gran lección porque es
tal vez la deuda pendiente que tiene la
región de América Latina y pues esto
deja en evidencia que efectivamente a
través de negociación y de buen
relacionamiento pues se puede lograr esa
integración así lo ha demostrado la
relación que han tenido Canadá Estados
Unidos en México a lo largo de los años
ya para el cierre del programa para
estos últimos minutos yo quiero que
ustedes escuchen esto
te deseo que te vaya bien
con mi su paso
estás tan raro que ni te distingo yo
valgo por dos de 22 cambiaste un Ferrari
por un twingo cambiaste un Rolex por un
Casio vas acelerado Dale despacio mucho
gimnasio pero trabajar el cerebro un
poquito también fotos por donde me ven
aquí me siento un rehén por mi todo bien
yo te desocupo mañana y si quieres
traertela a ella que venga también buena
parte de América Latina está en este
debate que es muy particular todo esto a
raíz de la presentación de esta reciente
canción de la cantante colombiana
Shakira en que se especula dice unas
cuantas verdades a su ex esposo el
futbolista Gerard Piqué ella no ha
confirmado que la letra de la canción
haya sido inspirada en el la reciente
separación que han vivido o que sea
enfocada hacia él la gente simplemente
asumió que estaba hablando de su ex
esposo Pero ha habido todo un revuelo a
nivel continental por la letra que si
está haciendo mala publicidad de algunas
marcas por enaltecer a otras marcas
comerciales por no pensar en hijos por
ser muy directa con su ex esposo a mí me
sorprendió un poco que estemos
debatiendo esto pero América Latina se
enfrasca en este tipo de debates cuando
hay cosas más importantes para conversar
Verónica opinión sobre este debate
profundo que está América Latina sobre
la canción de Shakira
Por supuesto me hace muy feliz que
estemos debatiendo esto Me encanta que
esta semana haya cerrado así
Creo que bueno Shakira tiene una
trayectoria de años es una latina muy
querida fuera de no solo aquí sino fuera
de la región
y pues bueno Por supuesto que fue
directa
si si guardando un poco la duda si es
verdad lo que se reportó y las
infidelidades y todo pues lo que ella
vivió en su relación me parece que es
una gran catarsis
en su opinión
me parece que hablar de indirectas ya
cuesta mucho caso son la letra bastante
directa en cierto momento esta parte
salpique o cuando habla de claramente
No creo que que hayan dudas sobre A
quién van estas canciones
de qué se trata Entonces lo otro es
cuando habla de esto de que ya no llora
tiene que factura ella está facturando
enormemente la canciones han conseguido
un montón de visitas y eso es innegable
ha sido un éxito que puede Yo desperté
una noche y ya había ya eran cuarenta
millones de reproducciones algo entonces
pero eran millones de reproducciones
menos de una noche una locura sí Lo que
sí es cierto es que logró ser un impacto
inmediato en las redes sociales un
impacto comercial la vamos a seguir
oyendo seguramente a lo largo de las
últimas semanas para el cierre me queda
un minuto para terminar el programa en
Qué temas estarán poniendo ustedes el
ojo para la próxima semana en sus
redacciones bastianna con la ronda la
inversa comienzo con usted
perfecto yo lo que Honestamente me tiene
muy atento es lo que se desarrolla con
Brasil más que nada con el con la
posible la casi más imposible amnistía
que se hallaba para los presos de esto y
también el desarrollo de Perú lo otro
que me preocupa un poco pero es más
lejano porque en dos semanas más se
cumplen los dos años de golpe de estado
en birmania en el mar Sí y hay que estar
también atento a lo que ocurre allá
también hay elecciones
Verónica rápidamente cuarenta segundos
coincido plenamente con mi compañero Por
supuesto Brasilia Me parece muy
importante y por supuesto Perú me
gustaría enfocarlo más en las víctimas
mortales de las manifestaciones
pues Sebastián a Verónica les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros ya ustedes
saben Cuál va a ser el tema musical del
fin de semana seguramente ustedes lo van
a estar oyendo en sus dispositivos los
dejamos así aquí en una semana en el
mundo en France 24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]